au fin fond des bois se trouve en
village rempli de petits schtroumpfs
heureux et joyeux la deux est beau comme
un dieu est pourvu d'un charme fou et lu
de voix chaude et puissante
chaque mot qu'il prononce est un enjeu
dont je trouve narrateur on a compris
bon d'accord mais non loin de l'île le
méchant sorcier gargamel où mijote un
plan diabolique
elle abrite les travaux créatifs pour
pouvoir enfin capturer je trouve
je l'espère et cana
koné ça a marché
d'après
leurs animations
l'iphone à managua voici mon plan pour
qu'elle devienne une cavale comme on dit
elle s'amusera tellement qu'elle voudra
plus jamais ne crie au ciel je défaille
ne craignez rien la schtroumpfette ne
sera jamais une canaille pourquoi cette
route aussi lentement
sanaria la drogue les schtroumpfs
trop
c'est bon je trouve les gars ça c'est
une excellente imitation